maybe most actors that I know have
terrible lives I don't just mean because
they don't make any money like most
actors don't make any money I mean their
personal lives are just get wrecked and
more so than my friends who are in other
Industries well again think about what
they do all day the focus of their life
is on them and being in front of a
screen and then on a big screen where
everybody can clap and tell you how
great you are and everybody around you
probably to not get pushed off the team
is telling you what you want to hear and
your life is so focused on you think
about all the marriages like it's a joke
people say if you last 10 years in
Hollywood that's like you're 75 years in
real life because it's and then you
spend half your year away from each
other
filming love scenes with other women how
on Earth is that going to work